voici un appareil qui mesure tous les
jours quatre fois par heure le niveau de
celle du ruisseau cosqueville à
mississauga
le fise la protection de la nature de
créer des deux vallées en installer une
dizaine il ya quelques années
il explique que la surveillance
constante a permis de détecter des
niveaux de sel qu'il n'avait jamais vue
auparavant
par exemple le 16 janvier dernier la
salinité de ce we saw était comparable à
celle de l'eau de mer il 72 fois plus
élevé que la recommandation de santé
canada pour l'eau potable le fait se
servent que d'autres cours d'eau qui
traverse les zones urbaines atteindre
ces niveaux de sel en hiver pas s'il
ment assez élevé pour l'heure pour le
goûter pour goûter de seine les
scientifiques affirment que c'est tout
l'écosystème qui souffre de la salinité
des cours d'eau les aime beaucoup
d'organismes qui ne peuvent pas vivre
le système avec 30 de celle de l'eau qui
menace entre autres des poissons des
moules et des tortues d'eau douce
selon lui certains lacs comme le lac
simcoe commence aussi à devenir salée ça
ça m'inquiète aussi parce que les lacs
sont dingues
il ya beaucoup d'eau si on peut voir le
niveau de celles qui ont commencé
d'accumuler dans les lacs
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de celle
qui est qui est ajoutée la ville de
toronto et pendant des dizaines de
milliers de tonnes de sel dans ses rues
chaque hiver on dépend des transports
pour nos biens et services et les gens
doivent être en sécurité lorsqu'ils se
rendent au travail explique-t-il
la ville affirme avoir réduit son usage
de ciel de 10% depuis 2003 ont su
l'utiliser
l'épandage du sel des groupes de défense
de l'environnement crois qu'il est temps
que les gouvernements encadrent
l'épandage du sel avoir une certaine
réglementation au niveau de
l'utilisation de la souris d'utilisation
vaisselle et d'avoir une certification
auprès des entrepreneurs qui s'occupe du
déglaçage
selon le fonds mondial pour la nature 5
millions de tonnes de sel sont épandues
sur les routes du canada
chaque hiver il c'est une plaie radio
canada toronto